hallo leute hier ist wieder eure mal
wandel und heute habe ich nie etwas ganz
besonderes für euch ausgedacht ihr wisst
ja ich zeichne immer so gerne da dachte
ich mir einfach mal weil ich so ein
tolles buch habe das ist nämlich die
kunst des zeichnens findet ihr
eigentlich in jedem fachhandel für für
zeichen bücher findet ihr einfach dieses
buch das ganze neu die großen
zeichenschule praxisnah und gut erklärt
und da kann ich sagen das stimmt top und
da wollte ich mich dann über zeigen also
wir brauchen einfach ein blatt papier
soll so ganz normales weiß der größe der
iris haben und dadurch noch ein paar
mehreren sein falls der erste versuch
nicht ganz rund da kann man halt immer
schön die zeichen eigentlich mit ganz
normaler bleistiften ein haar ganz
wichtig zum vorzeichnen bei der 2b um es
ein bisschen dunkler zu machen und am
ende dann richtig die schatten zu setzen
den 6 so da habe ich mir halt gedacht
nehmen wir mal was ganz tolles so eine
katze das habe ich schon mal vorher
ausgesucht das ist eine perserkatze die
ist auch ganz flauschig doch seht ihr
dies richtig schön kuschelig darauf ab
dass wir tolle haare sie hat könnte
möchte man sie am liebsten grauen so
will ich wissen
da würde ich einfach sagen fangen wir
mal an und schauen was dabei rauskommt
[Musik]
das jetzt meine katze jetzt noch so als
kleiner tipp das kennen viele schon aus
meinen anderen videos da benutze ich
manchmal so kleine hilfsmittel zum
beispiel wie diesen hier ich weiß man
das erkennen kann ob der fokus darauf
ist das ist ein manhattan kajalstift in
black 1 0 1 0
mit diesen kajalstift das setzt sich der
katze jetzt noch so ein bisschen
dramatik und die kriegt jetzt hier noch
so lieb wimpern ist ja lustig weil das
ziel drogerie stift kriegt sie noch ein
bisschen wimpern sie das hier so ein
bisschen weibliche aussieht dass ich
habe mich schon dass es eine weibliche
katze ist seht ihr was das für ein
toller effekt gibt weil das ja eine
weibliche katze ist habe ich mir
überlegt ihr so ein bisschen roten löwen
zu gehen das ist ja eigentlich bei
katzen nicht so üblich aber ich dachte
mir einfach ja da habe ich ein vom
himmel das ist in der farbe 230 red
vorverkauf den euch einfach nach also
wir müssen auf jeden fall kaufen einfach
kaufen hier nimmt die katze und malt ihr
so ein bisschen die lippen nach dann ist
das eine weibliche katze vielleicht
kennt ihr auch ausnahmen noch für sie
ausdenken wie wäre es mit moschee da
könnt ihr eigentlich ganz kräftig sein
wir nennen sie jetzt einfach mal moschee
damit das auch darauf erpicht ist dann
weiß auch jeder bescheid tschüs loki der
leute wenn ich dieses video gefallen hat
dann schaltet beim nächsten mal wieder
ein wenn es euch nicht gefällt hat dann
trotzdem
die skeptischen zu haben
vielleicht habt ihr ideen das bewies
bezeichnen kann und ja bis zum nächsten
mal eure mal wanne